I also have a 3 year old. This is now my third 3 year old.
And god speed to anyone with a child aged 2 to 4,
because holy shit.
After my last round of raising toddlers nearly killed me,
I started reading a couple books
and I found out
that the reason why people talk so much shit on teenagers
is the same reason that they talk on toddlers.
And it's actually for a very similar reason.
They are going through a very similar brain developmental leap
around that age where they are testing boundaries,
they're pushing boundaries,
they are asserting their individuality.
I know we joke that we have three natures,
but it's actually very similar.
So although I don't have a teenager yet,
I have a ten year old, she's about to be 10.
So we're about to crest into this phase.
I am certain that it's going to feel a lot like a more dangerous,
more independent three major phase.
But I think if I hold on to the fact that it is a developmental leap,
a developmental brain stage very much like toddlerhood,
I think I'll be able to emotionally handle it better.
At least. Here's hoping.